“Mathematics will fall first”, to being
solved by AI, that is, said Francois Fleuret
on December 3rd.
Now, on December the 13th, DeepMind published
this paper in Nature having found new solutions
in math and computer science with large language
models or short LLMs.
How did large language models that are known
to hallucinate and give so many bogus answers
become such incredible math solvers overnight?
That’s what we’ll explain in this video.
So, how can it be that LLMs can make scientific
discoveries when they are known to hallucinate
and produce factually incorrect information?
Well, let’s remember that they are also
quite creative at times.
And there is a fundamental difference between
everyday natural language problems and mathematics
or code:
Math and code have the great property of verifiability,
in other words: once we have a correct solution
to a math or coding problem,
we know whether it is correct, as we see that
the code compiles and that the result is what
we expected.
So, while LLMs produce piles of garbage,
the pile comes with some nuggets of creativity.
If there only was a way to decide which generations
are garbage and which ones are genius.
Well, there is this new idea in the LLM-space
of investing compute at test time, after the
generation:
Suppose we have a problem formulated as an
LLM prompt: Then, we let the model generate
a million answers.
Then we let a verifier rate and rank these
million answers.
The verifier could be a test we have written,
or even the same model that generated the
answers, or another capable model.
And yes, even the same model that generated
the answers will be quite good at rating its
own answers because quality estimation is
much easier than generation.
Think of it this way: it is much easier to
say whether this solution is correct or not,
than come up with it yourself.
And since math and code problems are verifiable,
one can use such verification tests to rank
the top solutions.
This is a recipe for how to select genius
answers from a wide range of not-so-good model
outputs.
The key insight behind the idea of test time
computation is that the model has been training
for months on internet-scale data and has
achieved a certain amount of capability (so
the capacity to perform a task) by transforming
its inputs layer by layer and arriving at
the answer.
But to increase the competency (so the level
of skill on a task), we could give it some
thinking time during inference, by letting
it produce many answers, like a million, and
rank those and let it make further computation
with those.
In other words,
we are replacing the reasoning we were expecting
from the model parameters,
with brute force computation at inference
time.
Now, how did DeepMind use this idea in their
Nature paper to develop FunSearch, to solve
long standing math and computer science problems?
Well, because of what we said previously about
code verifiability, you maybe are not very
surprised that for solving math and computer
science problems, they expressed them as code.
First, a mathematician describes the problem
in code and writes the tests that evaluate
the problem (to tell apart correct from wrong
solutions).
The mathematician also writes an initial program
as a placeholder for the solution.
By doing so, they specify the expected structure
of the solution.
So, the whole thing is more like a skeleton
and it’s useful to put prior knowledge we
have about the problem.
Then, an LLM iteratively improves the initial
program.
In principle the procedure could use any LLM
working with code, but the DeepMind authors
used Codey, which is a code LLM built on top
of PaLM 2.
So now, Codey improves this initial program
by generating many, many (a million) programs.
A lot of them are garbage, but some of them
are great.
The programs are automatically evaluated on
many inputs by the test functions written
by the mathematician.
For each input, programs get a score and the
final score of the program is an aggregate
over all inputs.
Code that does not compile, uses more memory
or time than allowed or does not deliver valid
results,
was discarded.
But code that gets high scores goes to a programs
database.
Then in the next iteration, FunSearch takes
a program from the program database as an
initial program (which is now better than
the last initialization).
Or rather, they use a couple of these best
programs to few-shot prompt the model, by
showing it a couple of initial programs sorted
by quality.
With these input programs, they repeat the
whole process of generating a million improvements,
ranking them based on how well they perform
on test inputs and put the best programs into
the program database,
from which they sample the initial program
in the next iteration again, favoring higher
scoring and shorter programs.
Okay, this was the method, but did they solve
actual problems with this?
Well, the authors wanted to solve the cap
set problem and collaborated with Jordan Ellenberg,
a mathematics professor at the University
of Wisconsin–Madison, known for making an
important breakthrough on the cap set problem.
The problem is about finding the largest set
of points (called a cap set) on a high dimensional
grid, where no three points are on a line.
What seems to be a weird graph theory problem,
is a model for other problems in extremal
combinatorics, asking how large or small a
set of objects can be.
Famous mathematician Terence Tao
described this as his favorite open question.
This problem is extremely hard to brute force
because the number of possibilities to consider
becomes extremely large super fast: larger
than the number of atoms in the universe,
which are 10^82.
Trust me, I’ve counted.
Now, FunSearch’s solutions were programs
that discovered the largest cap sets for some
settings that were never found before.
The authors say that “This is the largest
increase in the size of cap sets in the past
20 years.”
The authors from DeepMind did not stop at
the cap set problem and went onto the bin
packing problem in computer science.
Here the problem is to determine how to pack
items of different sizes into the smallest
number of bins.
This has numerous applications in real life,
think of how to pack your suitcases when flying
overseas, loading containers into ships, or
loading data into your computer memory, or
allocating jobs on a cluster.
Usually, this problem is solved by heuristics
devised by humans.
But it is hard to find good heuristics for
each specific situation.
FunSearch automatically gave specific programs,
adapted to the specifics of the data and situations,
outperforming human heuristics.
Now, FunSearch helping make these breakthroughs
is huge news, if you ask me and I was super
impressed and yes, maybe mathematics is a
domain where AI can be already put to use,
especially since verifiability is easier than
with other domains.
FunSearch has shown that one can usefully
leverage imperfect and hallucinatory LLMs,
as long as one has the compute to produce
a million of them per iteration, at least.
Jordan Ellenberg, the mathematician collaborating
with DeepMind on the cap set problem, said
that “The solutions generated by FunSearch
are far conceptually richer than a mere list
of numbers.
When I study them, I learn something.”,
which might mean AI will become a tool for
mathematicians to aid their discoveries in
the near future.
Here is what the Fields Medalist Hugo Duminil-Copin
said after I asked him about AI in mathematics
at the last Heidelberg Laureate Forum
What do you think of FunSearch?
Are you worried of AI taking over mathematicians
jobs?
Should you now switch fields and give up mathematics?
Well, it is on you to decide, but I would
rather say that an interesting time is coming
for mathematics, and it might get very busy
and vibrant there.
It’s not like AI will solve math by itself,
because these AIs are not independent: remember,
FunSearch needed the input of the mathematician
and the problem description and tests to be
able to work.
But thanks to AI, you could make use of some
programming skills and solve problems that
you were not able to crack before!
Thanks for watching this far.
If you want to see more videos like this one,
subscribe to the channel.
See you next time!
Okay, bye!